io mi chiamo antonio sono un amante
degli insetti e da qui nasce la passione
per quello che vorrei diventasse il mio
mestiere l'apicoltura prima di parlarvi
di apicoltura o di apicultura urbana nel
senso stretto
vorrei presentarvi le api darvi la
possibilità di riconoscerle e
distinguerle le api appartengono al
regno degli imenotteri all'interno di
questo regno possiamo distinguere due
sottoclassi la classe dei predatori e la
classe delle prede tra i predatori
troviamo le vespe le vespe facile
riconoscere le sue labbra anno
un'armatura sono carnivore vanno a
mangiare sempre il pesce alla carne per
noi mangiamo sulle tavole è il più
pericoloso tra le vespe diciamo che il
calabrone ma ognuno di questi insetti si
difende non attacca mai all'uomo per
sfizio tra le prede troviamo le api tra
le alpi ci sono i bombi ci sono le api
solitarie facile riconoscere perché sono
sempre più pelose un po più tozze la più
interessante delle api e lapis mellifera
è l'unica che l'uomo alleva per produrre
miele le api vivono in un alveare
all'interno di ardere c'è una regina
centinaia di funghi che la casta
maschile e migliaia di api operaie nel
pieno della stagione verso luglio agosto
un alveare può raggiungere fino a 80
mila individui
questo ci fa pensare come calabroni e
vespe predano le api quindi le api sono
delle prede
l'importanza delle api non risiede nella
produzione di miele potremmo anche farne
a meno del miele ma delle api no perché
le api sono importanti per
l'impollinazione
c'è un'intera famiglia di piante le
angiosperme che ha affidato la propria
riproduzione alle api e quindi grazie a
queste api le angiosperme i fiori si
sono riprodotti in tante varietà voi
pensate che di tutte queste piante da
fiore di solito le angiosperme sono
quelle che hanno i fiori colorati di
tutti questi fiori le api sono
responsabili per l'ottanta per cento
della loro riproduzione
anche l'uomo si nutre di queste piante e
quindi noi ci nutriamo di frutta come
mele pere
arance indossiamo jeans di cotone che
impallinato dalle api mangiamo la carne
che va al pascolo e il pascolo e di
prodotto dalle api per un buon 50 per
cento di quello che noi mangiamo
dobbiamo dire grazie alle api e quindi
le api possiamo dire che sono le garanti
della biodiversità e sono quelle che ci
aiutano a sopravvivere
infatti da un po di anni a questa parte
rimbalza sempre una frase di einstein
non si sa se sia vera sarebbe detto lui
o meno questa frase
dice senza le api a l'uomo all'uomo
restano quattro anni di vita
prescindere se l'abbia detto meno in sta
in una frase vera perché senza le api
non ci sono i fiori non ci sono i frutti
e quindi non ci sono gli erbivori non ci
sono i carnivori e di conseguenza non
c'è l'uomo
il problema è che forse abbiamo subito
un po troppo tardi questo messaggio
infatti le api stanno morendo
le api da almeno 10 anni muoiono per
cause tuttora sconosciute in realtà non
sappiamo perfettamente qual è la causa
scatenante della moria c'è una comunità
scientifica che sta cercando di indagare
ma non perché sappiamo le api per
salvare il miele salviamo le api per
salvare l'uomo e quindi c'è un'intera
comunità scientifica che sta indagando
nei luoghi dove le api vengono applicate
ovvero la campagna quella che noi
abbiamo sempre pensato essere l'amica
degli apicoltori amica dell'uomo oggi
sta diventando una grande nemica e
infatti noi vediamo che in campagna c'è
la monocultura ormai esiste l'industria
alimentare non esiste più la bella
campagna il posto bucolico no perché gli
uomini aumentano sempre di più e quindi
l'agricoltura si industrializza la
monocultura non offre più cibo alle api
gli agricoltori devono nutrire
artificialmente le api questa
agricoltura sopravvivere grazie
pesticidi che è la prima causa
scatenante della moria delle api e poi
non basta solo questo ci sono i
cambiamenti climatici ci sono
l'inquinamento delle falde acquifere
tanti problemi che portano alla moria
delle api ma è la stessa di coltura
intensiva che le sta distruggendo perché
a forza di stressarle per produrre miele
produciamo prodotti le api reagiscono in
malo modo
la fortuna è che ci sono tanti
scienziati che studiano questi problemi
ma il problema più grande è che a volte
queste ricerche vengono finanziate dagli
stessi fautori dell'impoverimento del
terreno quindi non esiste una verità
oggettiva ad ora non sappiamo perché le
api muoiono fatto sta che le api muoiono
come stanno reagendo le api e bene le
api migrano perché le api non sono come
tutti gli animali d'allevamento sono
animali selvatici
gli apicoltori danno solo uno spazio
migrano e sapete dove vanno in città
paradossalmente le api migrano verso la
città quella che noi abbiamo sempre
pensato essere inquinante scappiamo cioè
nella città noi invece le api le hanno
scelte quindi è importante capire per
quale motivo e motivi anche qui son
tanti prima di tutto perché la città ha
biodiversità la città non deve produrre
cibo dalle piante quindi le piante
ornamentali arricchiscono la dieta delle
api
il clima mite l'attenzione delle persone
e quindi sempre di più nascono progetti
di apicultura urbana
l'agricoltura urbana e diffusa new york
a londra dove ci sono 10 mila alveari
a hong kong a melbourne in tutte le più
grandi metropoli del mondo e in italia
non esisteva nulla
noi siamo stati i primi un po portare
avanti questa pratica e così abbiamo
iniziato anche noi con una squadra di
amici e volontari a raccogliere gli
sciami che arrivavano in città questi
sciami arrivano si posano sui segnali
stradali sulle bici sui cornicioni
noi andiamo li prendiamo e invece di
riportarle in campagna per evitare che
poi ritorni nelle città gli diamo la
giusta sistemazione
stiamo prendendo accordi con vari enti
vari stabili per poter posizionare le
api direttamente in città e quindi
abbiamo realizzato un apiario
all'interno di una casa di quartiere nel
quartiere mirafiori
noi siamo di torino in questo quartiere
cioè la fiat sul tetto di questa casa di
quartiere ci sono tre alveari le api
stanno benissimo tutto e tutti contenti
e non è l'unica piano che abbiamo
realizzato
ne abbiamo creato anche uno in un museo
abbiamo chiesto alta emanueli branche
l'autore di questa opera che si chiama
da folli e rappresenta un giardino
ottocentesco se potevamo mettere le api
lì dentro e lui stato contentissimo
perché è un museo di arte contemporanea
ed è molto focalizzato sui temi
ambientali e quindi ha detto mettere le
api in quest'opera può essere un
completamento e noi l'abbiamo fatto ci
siamo spinti oltre
abbiamo installato anche un apiario
urbano su un balcone esattamente sul
balcone di casa mia io abito a torino in
pieno centro in un condominio signorile
quarto piano e ci sono tre alveari
vicini si sono lamentati all'inizio poi
hanno scoperto che le api vanno sui
fiori e che non interessa l'uomo alle
api quindi le api pensate escono dal
nido e vanno in linea retta sul fiore
quindi non causa nessun problema vicini
anzi ci procura un po di cibo po di
miele e quindi è perfetto
abbiamo realizzato circa 6 apiari a
torino ne sono stati realizzati altri
non utilizzeremo ancora altri da
pubblici e privati cittadini
diciamo che la città di torino ha
reagito positivamente la nostra proposta
alla proposta la possibilità di allevare
le api come hobby come passione ogni
cittadino può allevarle per dare un
rifugio alternativo alle api
per procurarci del miele autoprodurci
del miele e per impollinare le piante
della città perché senza le api le
piante non si impugnano e così noi
abbiamo visto le api non solo come
produttrici di miele perché attenzione
alle api la vera importanza non è la
produzione di miele e quindi siccome in
città si riparte da zero abbiamo pensato
perché non utilizzare le api come
bioindicatori e allora nasce il progetto
il business il valore aggiunto rispetto
a tutti gli altri progetti di
agricoltura urbana nel mondo
se guardiamo un alveare un area in media
circa 50.000 p di queste 50mila e 10mila
sono le raccoglitrici ognuna di questa
di queste raccoglitrici si sposta di
circa un chilometro e mezzo due
dell'alveare occupando un'area di 7
chilometri quadri ognuna di queste api
visita circa mille fiori al giorno
quindi voi pensate se noi guardiamo un
alveare come una centralina ambientale
che ci dà una un'indicazione
sull'ambiente questa centralina effetto
a 10 milioni di micro prelievi in
ambiente non c'è nessuna tecnologia
capace di fare una cosa del genere e di
stoccare tutte queste informazioni
nell'alveare da queste informazioni
stiamo sviluppando due filoni di ricerca
il primo filone riguarda la biodiversità
grazie all'analisi sul miele sul polline
lo possiamo scoprire quali sono le
piante della città creare un atlante
botanico e capire un po come fare a
mettere delle piante favorevoli alla
vita di questi me lottery perché inutile
piantare delle piante che siano belle
solo estetiche no le piante in città la
vegetazione urbana deve essere
funzionali alla natura altrimenti è un
pato inglese che non serve quasi a nulla
se non alla bellezza
secondo filone di ricerca e
l'inquinamento quindi gli apici possono
dare informazioni anche
sull'inquinamento
analizzando i componenti dall'alveare le
api stesse che volano il miele da c'era
il polline la propoli possiamo scoprire
in che quantità e di che qualità è
l'ambiente e gli inquinanti quindi
possiamo scoprire quali metalli pesanti
ci sono come piombo nichel cromo
radionuclidi pesticidi idrocarburi
quindi le api integrano gli studi che
vengono effettuati oggi per studiare la
qualità ambientale che lo fanno le api
lo può fare anche qualsiasi cittadino
quindi non deleghiamo più il
biomonitoraggio e l'attenzione
dell'ambiente ad altri possiamo farlo
noi stessi e così stiamo dimostrando
attraverso il nostro piccolo che si
possono avere le app in città non
bisogna essere per forza apicoltori
professionisti per averli e contribuire
al benessere sociale della città così
dal 2012 2013 e 2014 abbiamo iniziato a
raccogliere dei campioni borghese non ha
dei finanziamenti si autofinanzia
quindi abbiamo iniziato ad accogliere i
campioni di miele e analizzati per
scoprire saranno commestibili quindi
iniziamo a capire se il miele può essere
distribuito o meno per nostra grande
fortuna è sorpresa abbiamo scoperto che
miri urbani non sono inquinati sebbene
torino sia una città molto inquinata le
api sono capaci di filtrare
l'inquinamento e di dare al prodotto
miele una grande qualità
e quindi
abbiamo raccolto mieli nel 2012 13 e 14
dobbiamo iniziare ad inseguirli e
abbiamo creato una nostra linea di
prodotto prima di pensare al miele come
nutrimento
noi vediamo il miele come un veicolo di
informazione e quindi all'interno
dell'etichetta abbiamo installato un
qrcode tramite il quale il consumatore
può collegarsi ad un sito internet e
scoprire la qualità dell'ambiente e le
caratteristiche del miele quindi miele
diventa un libro un qualcosa da leggere
tutti possono informarsi sulla qualità
ambientale non bisogna per forza essere
produttore di miele o consumatori di
miele c'è un sito si va nel sito e si
scopre qual è la qualità della vita
all'interno del quartiere in cui si vive
solo alla fine di questo processo
il miele finalmente si può mangiare poi
ci siamo divertiti a dare nomi strani e
mieli visto che in città si fanno solo
millefiori e non vogliamo fare solo
millefiori abbiamo dato il nome ai mieli
a seconda del luogo di raccolta quindi
esiste il miele antonio che il miele
fatto sul mio balcone
esiste il miele elvira fatto nell'orto
urbano di elvira esiste il miele pub e
il papa il museo e il miele bunker che è
un'altra realtà in cui abbiamo le api e
il miele andrea perché andrea è un altro
pickle torre che ci sta sostenendo
abbiamo messo delle api a casa su
abbiamo creato il miele andrea quindi
ognuno può personalizzare i mieli cioè
possiamo inventarci l'apicoltura urbana
eco dandogli però un
un'etica sociale non solo per produrre
il proprio miele ma per dare un
contributo alla città e quindi cos'è in
estrema sintesi il progetto il bis noi
raccogliamo gli sciami della città li
mettiamo nelle arnie gli diamo una
giusta sistemazione
diamo la possibilità alle api di andare
a raccogliere tutte queste informazioni
per raccogliere nettare polline propoli
eccetera
le analizziamo queste matrici queste
risorse e invase ti amo tutto in un
barattolo che contiene sia
un'informazione che è un nutrimento ci
autofinanziamo la ricerca grazie alla
distribuzione del miele i cittadini che
mangiano il vero urbano mangiano un
pezzo di città assaggiano la città
perché così è la sintesi di un luogo il
miele non è come il vino l'olio che
viene fuori da una flute no vanno a
prendere tanti pezzetti e creano il
miele e da qui possono nascere tante
iniziative non vogliamo dimostrare che
tutti possono fare apicoltura possano
tutti possono salvaguardare le api e
possono dare un senso diverso alla città
quindi se vogliamo costruire città
sostenibili
possiamo partire anche dalle api e
quindi anziché fare città a misura
d'uomo non vorremmo costruire città a
misura da pe dove l'ape e il testimone
della sostenibilità ecologica della
città
grazie